welcome to watchdog leisure welcome to
watchdogs cut down eight welcome to GTA
London watchdogs legion's is the
follow-up from the ambitious but not
great watchdogs and the much improved
watchdogs to a game which lets you ride
a motorcycle over a sports car and feel
like a complete badass no in fact it
makes you feel like a real-life Londoner
ah
I've played three hours and I have to
admit I really do like this game playing
as a covert group of military trained
badasses are ready to take down the
authority and bring freedom back to the
streets of New York okay it's nothing
like that the main selling point of
Legion is the ability to recruit anyone
on the streets of London seemingly
helpless individuals and actually find
out they possess skills like no other a
nail gun wielding construction worker
ready to fight why are you ready fine
now here we go let's see if she's got
she's got it this is going to seconds
later okay bad example how about an
elderly Chinese dude who literally run
slower than he walks I am no threat to
anyone what is this police brutality
okay are they gonna stop will they
literally beat me to a bar no I know rip
mr. Yip or even a girl hitman who
carries a Desert Eagle
but forgets how gravity works you know
what Oh in fact I'm getting out of here
how would a special agent get down like
this Jason Bourne Oh
yeah she's not Jason Bourne but she's
almost Jason Bourne she has better
stilettos the possibilities here are
endless each character we recruit has a
unique skill which we can see before we
recruit them like breaking people's
faces with a baseball bats which is
satisfying or choking the lure on paint
fumes which satisfy some go invisible
some can hit 3 treble 20s in a row and
hit the double first time I hate dance
there are thousands of NPCs to discover
all with differing backstories and
character traits such as Hamish bowler
gee who hates it when people
mispronounce his name we found one his
name Hamish Balaji
let's move on to the hacking in the game
it is fantastic you can force cars to
drive out of your way clearing the roads
you can even run down enemies with a
taxicab he doesn't he doesn't suspect a
thing
now imagine getting run over by a taxi
damn it the hacking takes place
everywhere does Hackham cameras hacking
things that blow up
akhom it's great and you're hacking
takes into account the real-time secret
information you need to download hacking
in real time stay close don't walk away
stay stay I'm a secret agent then after
nowhere the game becomes CSI Miami and
CGI recreations take over
uh-huh that's right all this tech is
here to break up the core gameplay loop
which is driving to a location shooting
people and downloading info but
sometimes cool things happen like this
reconnecting power lines just like they
do in real life using a mobile phone and
a blue line the future is here my
friends and when everything becomes too
intense we can simply do this in a
nutshell from what I've played watchdogs
Legion is a vast improvement on the
other games in the series with that core
mechanic of recruiting different
operatives being the real hook here it's
brilliant
figuring out which operative is the
right one for the right mission for
example in this mission it requires a
special keycard it can be found hidden
in this building somewhere but some
characters already have that ID and can
walk straight through this door I should
have found an Albion agent to recruit
but I have a better idea come on come
closer you can open this door that's how
you choose the system now you know the
painter and decorator is so opie let's
do this the great things about this game
are the multiple characters to choose
from being in London is pretty great we
haven't been here very often in video
games the hacking is awesome and the
variety of options before you go on a
mission keep this game interesting on
the negative side though the voices are
tremendously over-the-top and you'll
hear the same voices constantly at least
10 people on the street you are on have
the exact same voice as the character
you play us but the worst thing that I
now know after playing the preview is
that permadeath has been removed from
the game I know I'm gutted too so that's
watchdogs Legion in a nutshell thanks
for your time I'll see you next time
[Music]